Phoebe attend Oh Bob is a busy mother of
five she's an entrepreneur and a
vegetable and livestock farmer until
about six months ago she lived off her
small patch of land but like many
small-scale farmers in western Kenya she
was only just getting by I used to do
the farming and also the millet and meat
so because of short rains we don't get
enough enough enough harvesting the
harvesting is not very good but she has
labourers now and she's been able to set
up a small restaurant a dream come true
thanks to funds from a charity called
give directly instead of putting some
some shares of my little little potatoes
Utah so when they you directly pay me
the money I see whoo-hah this is God's
plan of what unlike other charities
money from give directly is not
conditional on a set development plan or
retraining Phoebe and other households
in the village were simply given a
one-off payment of about one thousand
euros they could use the money any way
they wanted no strings attached the idea
was to give people cash instead of aid
which is what give directly did for some
time now they're experimenting with
different models
some people like Phoebe get a one-off
lump sum others get a basic income a
small amount each month we have seen
that when we give our lump sum transfers
there has been 27 percent increase in
assets
and we want to test whether if we give
people money long-term through a basic
income model whether we can see similar
or even better outcomes in their offices
in Nairobi the staff is registering
people for a mammoth 12-year study some
6000 people will receive around 20 euros
per month for the next 12 years together
with economists from MIT and Princeton
the charity wants to see whether this
form of stable income can really make an
impact on people's lives so basically we
have field offices sit here each and
every day and what they do is call
recipients out in the villages who we
have sent money to find out whether
they've received the money if they had
any problem during the transfer what
they've used the money for back in the
countryside the first villages in the
basic income project have started
receiving cash and although they don't
have to the people have set up their own
checks and balances spending money is a
communal affair so they've organized
banking groups villagers put a share of
their money into a common pool then each
month one person in the group will get
just under 100 euros from the pool that
they can put toward a bigger investment
when you combust in the meeting the next
meeting you say what you use the manual
used for if you used it for paying
school fees or buying chairs or whatever
you used for we want the feedback in
technology from school fees to
renovating homes buying food when the
crops fail there's always something to
spend the money on
so however small the some many people in
this Western Kenyan village welcome the
extra cash